JD VELASQUEZ: So my name is JD.
I'm a Senior Product
Manager in Google.
And with me is John Banning,
who is a Staff Software
Engineer and the technical
lead for the Stackdriver Query
Notation, which we are
very excited to introduce
to you today.
So we're going to
be talking about how
to incrementally build powerful
queries with the Stackdriver
Query Notation.
And also how that gives you
more flexibility and power
to increase the observability
of your applications
and your
infrastructure, whatever
you use in Google Cloud.
But before we get going, I'd
love to know a little bit more
about everybody here
in the audience.
So let's hear some hands.
So who here is a developer?
All right.
What about an operator or SRE?
And both?
[? Actually, ?] DevOps,
we're doing everything.
Yes, a few.
OK, cool.
Anybody who's a language geek?
Wow, good for you, awesome.
OK, so hopefully we'll have
several things for each
and one of you.
But this is an
intermediate-level talk.
We're going to go into the
nitty details of query language
that John essentially designed
and worked with a team.
But as I said, we're
hopefully going
to show you through demos and
other things how we get there.
So here's the plan.
We'll start with a brief
overview of observability
within Stackdriver,
and particularly
with the Query Notation and
introduce you to Query Notation
itself.
Then we'll jump straight into
details from the beginning.
And we're going to see
a lot of shorter demos
and showing how you can
actually use this language
to create these very
robust, powerful queries.
So John will spend a few
minutes talking about how
a basic query is formed.
And then he's going to build up
on that to create more queries.
And then we'll get into some
demos of advanced queries, then
to come back to the end,
recap, and then give you
some call to action so you
can actually get access
to Query Notation, use
it, and, of course,
please give us feedback.
So let's jump right in.
So of course in the end, we
do have time for questions.
We're going to
leave a few minutes.
So I'm sure there's
microphones up here
in the front, which you can use.
And if we run out of
time, we're, of course,
going to be also outside.
You can come and
talk to us as well.
So let's go right it
into observability.
So whether you're a
developer, or an operator SRE,
or you're doing both, or
you're just doing analysis,
and so on, there's always
that time when we all
wish we had just a little
more observability.
And maybe because you're
dealing with an incident
in your application.
And then your users are not
able to access their cards
and their checkout services.
Or maybe because you're
doing proactive monitoring
and you're really
trying to do analysis
on some specific state of your
application or infrastructure.
Or maybe because you want to
control a little bit of time
and you want to do
demand forecasting.
You want to look at how
your retail application is
doing now.
The demand is getting compared
to last season of Black Friday,
for instance.
And in those cases,
you really want
to be able to go and inspect
your systems, your applications
in detail.
Now many of
observability tools allow
you to do this in some ways,
very much in the same way
the Stackdriver does.
And we're going to offer
you another more powerful
and flexible means to do this.
So this is precisely
the whole idea
of being able to increase
and observability
for your cloud applications is
what Stackdriver's meant to do.
Stackdriver's a
product suite that
offers a comprehensive set of
tools that together provide
very rich observability
of your cloud environment,
your cloud services, your
application, and so forth.
And so the idea
that we're trying
to do in many of the
services, and today we're
going to focus primarily
on the monitoring side,
we're going to focus on
metrics and time series.
But the idea here
is that we want
to take the toil of doing
office management away from you
as much as possible.
Those things that
really are hard to do,
easily automatable,
and so forth,
we want to help you
take advantage of those,
so that you can
focus on what matters
most, which is your business
and your application.
And so to that end,
we've [? been on ?]
enormous machinery.
It's a set of systems that
we use internally at Google
to also how we monitor
and get observability
for many of our own products.
And so these systems
bring together
a lot of different things.
Building metrics, and logs, as
well as snapshots, and traces.
And we put all of
those together.
They're coming from
cloud services.
open source components.
They're coming from
cloud-native infrastructure,
even from other cloud providers.
And we aggregate and
put those together
to help create and infer
relationships between resources
to understand and evaluate
alerting policies to alert you
when a symptom of perhaps
the prediction of a failure
may come in.
And we give you a powerful
visualization tools
to do all of that.
So that always with the intent
of making ops easy for you
and increase the observability.
So again, if we focus
on the monitoring piece,
if we focus on metrics
and time series,
Stockdriver
monitoring, of course,
allows you to do this today.
You can expect on demand
in Stackdriver monitoring
using the metrics explorer.
Anybody here has used a
metrics explorer before?
A few of you.
Oh, wow, several of you.
Great.
So, for instance, you can look
at the CPU request utilization
metric for those Kubernetes
container resources.
You can filter them
by the namespace that
is-- let's say, the
default namespace that has
my application at this moment.
And I can group them by
container name and by location.
I certainly do
that with a metric
and get that on
demand-type of visibility,
but what if I want to
do something different?
What if I-- this may not
be enough and we know that.
Sometimes you want
to slice and dice
your time series
data and your metrics
in a way that is just
convenient to you
and maybe you want to
do composite metrics,
maybe you want to do
arbitrary math functions,
you want to control
time, and so forth.
So this is exactly
what we're doing today
by introducing the
Stackdriver query notation.
Stackdriver query notation is
a flexible and comprehensive
language that allows you
to do precisely that.
It allows you to build
powerful query metrics,
so you can inspect on
demand, so that you
can analyze the state of your
application and infrastructure,
and so that you can
build robust dashboards,
so you can do
proactive monitoring
or also so you can do
alerting, and then, in general,
increase the overall
observability
of your cloud workloads.
Now, the Stackdriver
query notation
is built on a
consistent data model.
So it provides a
very solid foundation
for all your query buildups.
It is also based on a
popular pipeline idiom,
so it's easier to incrementally
build and debug those queries
that you have.
And it also offers
powerful operators for you,
so-- to do precisely
the sort of things
that I mentioned--
composite queries, queries
of composing functions,
arbitrary math ratios, time
shifting, and so on, which
John is precisely going
to show us in a few minutes.
So just to get a sense of
how this work, let's do--
this is metrics explorer and
we have already here a standard
query set up-- the one
that we just mentioned
in the previous slide.
And what you can do is you
can click on a query editor
and that should give
you directly, now,
the equivalent of that--
essentially, the query that
you have now in query notation.
So notice what you have
here it's already group
by window, by name, and I have
another group by container
name, location, and so on.
And I immediately get
the same time series
that I would get otherwise.
Now, how-- if this was
all too fast, don't worry.
Because this is exactly where
we're going to be doing next.
John is going to take us
into the details of how
to start from a query like
this, and build up on that,
and show us as several
advance queries
as well to really get you
into how you can increase
observability of your apps.
So I'm going to hand
it off to John, who can
start on some of this journey.
JOHN BANNING: All right.
I think we go back to the
slides now and here we go.
We're going to go through the
query notation in seven steps.
I'm not going to read
this to you because we're
going to start right in.
So basic query.
The most basic query--
every query in
the query notation
starts with a fetch operation.
The fetch operation,
we see one here,
starts with the name
of the operation,
fetch, and one argument,
which is the name of a table.
When it evaluates, it's going to
find that table in the database
and return it or produce
it as it's output.
Now, you might be
saying, wait a minute,
we have metrics, we have time
series, what's this table thing
and what's a table name?
So let's look at
that for a minute.
Out in the cloud,
we've got resources
that we want to keep an eye on.
Here's a Kubernetes node.
And every kind of resource
has associated with it a--
let's see, yes-- a monitored
resource type, in this case,
k8s_node.
And then monitored
resource type gives us
a way to name that resource.
And it does so by giving
us a set of labels.
And every resource of that
kind will have a value
for each of those labels.
The project ID that owns the
resource, the location where
the resource resides or
is being monitored from,
and the cluster name
and node name that we're
given when that Kubernetes
is node was created,
and the monitor resource type,
and the value of those labels
uniquely identify every
Kubernetes node in the system.
Now-- oops.
Now, we're going to
have a number of metrics
on each one of these nodes that
we're going to be monitoring.
And each metric
has a metric type.
Here is a metric type for
allocatable utilization
on a node, the
fraction of memory
we could allocate that
we're actually using.
And the metric type
gives the type of value
that the metric is producing,
in this case, double gauge.
Gauge means that it's a state of
the system that we can observe
and that we'll sample,
to gather data from--
being the amount of memory
in use at that time.
The other stream
that we see typically
is a delta stream,
where each point
is the sum of some value
like the number of queries
I've received or the
number of CPU seconds
I've used over some
specific time period.
Now, the other thing that
might come with a metric type
are some labels.
This one comes with
one label called
the memory type,
which can be either
a evictable or non-evictable.
So there's two kinds of
memory and we'll, basically,
have two instances of this
metric with different values
for that label to track
the utilization of both
of those kinds of memory.
Now, these two things
together uniquely edify
a stream of data that we might
be interested in collecting
and we put them together in
what's called a time series
identifier.
The name of that time
series identifier
includes both the resource
name and the metric name,
has all of the labels from both
the resource and the metric,
and this uniquely
identifies a stream
of data that's coming in
from the cloud to Stackdriver
to be recorded.
Now, that we have a
name for a time series,
we can start collecting
at time series.
So a time series has an
identifier that uniquely
identifies it and a history.
So we get the history
and consists of values
that we've observed the metric
to have in the timestamp when
the observation was made.
Now, obviously, we have a lot
of nodes out in the cloud,
and they have a lot
of metrics, and so
we're going to have a
lot of these time series.
And you might think of this
slide as being reproduced--
once for each resource and
metric type and they'll
have different labels, but the
time series same-- time series
identifier uniquely identifying
the time series and a history
associated with it.
Now, in order to make these time
series accessible to queries,
we gather them together
in a time series table.
This is a straightforward
relational table.
It has columns, one column
for each of the times
series identifier labels,
a timestamp column--
whoops, sorry, there we go--
I went way too far, all right--
a timestamp column
and value column,
so every row in this table
represents one observation.
And that observation's time
is here and value there.
And the time series it's part of
is identified by these columns.
So you can think of this as
containing all of the time
series that involve
[INAUDIBLE],, Kubernetes node,
and this particular metric.
And so that's what the--
and the name of this table
is given by the resource
name and the metric name.
And so that is what the
fetch operation names
and the kind of table
that it's going to return.
All right.
Now, let's start building
queries from that base.
We build queries
with a pipe operator,
that's the method by which
parts of queries are composed.
Here the pipe operator that
connects different operations--
here we have the
fetch operation we
saw before connected by the pipe
operator to a filter operation
that we've added.
And the way this works
is the fetch operation
produces a table, it's
piped by the pipe operator
to be the input to the
filter operation, which
transforms that
table in some way,
and produces it as
output, which is then
the output of this query.
So we can see this
in this diagram.
There's the fetch operation.
It's producing a table
that's input to the filter
operation, which
transforms it in some way
and produces another
table as output.
Well, what does the fetch
operation filter operation
doing?
Pretty straightforward,
it's got one argument,
which is a general express--
is a Boolean expression that's
a predicate.
And we'll evaluate
that expression
on every row in the input table.
And those rows for which the
expression is true, we'll keep,
and those for which
is false, we'll drop.
This is a fairly
simple expression.
It's basically looking
at one column--
the value of one column
in the row and asking
does it start with
the word heapster?
If it does, it'll be true.
Otherwise, it'll be false.
We'll see more complex
expressions in a little bit.
So, basically, we're looking
at the container column
in all of the rows in the
table we're evaluating
the predicate on them.
We see the rows that have
the predicate returning true.
We throw away all the rows
where it returns false.
And this is the output
of the filter operation.
So this is a way to look at
some specific subset of the data
that you want-- that
you have in your table.
The other thing--
another thing you
might want to do is to get a
statistic about-- statistics
about all of the
things in the table
and that's done by the
group by operation.
So here we're piping the output
of the fetch into a group
by, which has two arguments.
The first is a map
expression, which
is going to tell us how to
construct the time series
identifier columns
in the output table.
And, here, they are constructed
by just taking the cluster name
field from the input
table stream ID
and that will be the
stream ID of the output.
And then the other part
is the aggregation--
I apologize, push on
the wrong buttons here--
the aggregation
expression, which
tells how to combine
the value columns
of rows that are mapped
to the same place by this.
So let's look at that
in a little more detail.
Here we're showing one
stream out of the table.
We have all of the stream ID
identifier column values here
and each row is represented
by a point in the table
with its timestamp.
And, basically, what we do--
what the map does is, basically,
transform this into this.
And this is now the time
series of the identifier,
the history remains unchanged.
Now, if we do that, we're going
to have a lot of time series
in the table with the same
time series identifier,
but we only want one
time series in the output
with that identifier.
So, basically, what
we're going to do
is to apply the
aggregator to these.
We take all of the points
at some particular time
and we apply the mean
aggregator to them,
getting the average
value, and that
goes into a point
in the output table
with the same timestamp
and the mean value.
And we keep doing
that at each timestamp
until we get to the end of the
table, at which point, now,
we have one output time
series for the output table.
We do this for every
value of cluster name,
so for every value
of cluster name,
there'll be another group
of time series like this
and we do the same thing.
And that's how we
produce the output table.
All right.
So let's look at
that a little bit--
in action.
We start with the basic fetch.
We can-- and we can see there's
quite a few times series up
on the screen here.
The-- and every
line on this screen
represents one time
series in the table
that was fetched by that fetch.
Now we can add a filter or this.
And what are we
going to do here?
We're going to look
at the namespace name.
We're going to look at
the default namespace.
And that's going to cut
down the rows that we have--
the [? street ?]
time series that we
have to a certain
smaller number of them.
And we're also
going to look at--
we can add further
predicates to that.
So we're going to only look--
some of these are
running on-prem,
we're only going to look
at the on-prem ones.
All right.
And once we've done that, now
we can look at a group by.
And this group by is throwing
away all of the time series
identifiers, so there's only
one stream in the output
and it has the default
aggregator, which is to sum.
But we can replace
that aggregator
with an explicit one.
We could say mean or we
could say standard deviation.
There's a very large number
of aggregators we could use.
But besides giving a single
aggregation function,
we can make an expression.
We could, for instance,
divide the standard deviation
by the mean to get the
coefficient of variation
and that's what we have.
So this is over all of the
containers in our application.
Now, the next thing we can do
is go to the map expression.
And here we're going to put
in this regular expression
extraction that extracts
the first component
in the name of the--
in the pod name
of our container--
everything up to the first dash.
And so this gives us
aggregated information
about each kind of container
that we are running.
All right.
Now, after I've gone to all
this trouble to make a query,
I might want to save it.
Well, you can do that.
There we go.
You can save it.
You give it a name and you
can save it to a dashboard.
You could create a
new one or-- we're
going to use an existing
one and we save it.
Think we save it?
Does it not want to save itself?
JD VELASQUEZ: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN BANNING: All right.
JOHN BANNING: We're
going to try that again.
JD VELASQUEZ: It's
the last day, John.
The demo gods are--
JOHN BANNING: They
are frowning on us?
All right.
JD VELASQUEZ: We'll get to it--
JOHN BANNING: You're
going to have to trust us.
You really can do this.
All right.
We would have gone to look
at the chart on the dashboard
and shown that you could
edit the chart again.
In fact, we could go to the
dashboard and just edit some
other chart-- just to
show that it is, in fact--
JD VELASQUEZ: Yep.
JOHN BANNING: --a useful thing.
So this is also a
way of, obviously,
of creating dashboard.
All right.
Here's one we saved
earlier today, just
to prove that we can do it.
And you go back and you
get a very similar editor
view of that.
All right.
So let's go back now
to the presentation.
So this is just for
the record, the group
by that we built before
with a little bit more here.
We've got an extra field
that we added to the mapping,
but this is pretty
much the same thing.
Now, let's see-- look at
some more advanced queries
from this.
This is the base
queries that we've got.
So here we go.
We're now up to point
five in our seven points.
And one of the things
that you might want to do
is to look at outliers.
That's always a lot
of fun, particularly
if your aggregation says,
well, there's something wrong.
Maybe you want to see
if there's something
wrong with specific things.
So for that you can
use the top operation.
It has two arguments.
The first says,
how many things do
you want to see out of the
collection of all the things?
And the second says, here
is how to select them.
So this is an
aggregation function,
max is an aggregation function.
It's applied to all of the
points in a time series
to get the maximum value
of that time series.
And then we look for the time
series, which the top five time
series for that value.
You can use any kind
of aggregator here,
mean is also a good one to use.
And you can also use bottom
here to look for things
with the smallest amount.
Another thing that you
often will want to do
is look at more than
one query at a time.
So far, we've just been
looking at one query.
Here we-- in order to do that,
you use these squiggly brackets
and join.
Between the squiggly brackets
you have multiple queries.
Here are the queries are very
simple, just a fetch operation.
But they could be general
queries put together by pipes,
separated by semicolons.
So this, basically, produces
two different tables,
one for each of the queries.
Those two tables, then, are
piped into the join, which
combines them into one table.
But that table now has
two value columns, one
from each of the input tables.
And that can be piped into a div
operation, which takes the two
values, takes the--
divides them, and
produces a single ratio,
and a single value
column table for output.
So let's look at that
in a little more detail.
So here is how tables are piped
through the join operation.
Each of the two queries
produces a table.
Those two tables
are independently
input into the join,
which combines the two
tables into one table
with two value columns.
The div takes that table
with two value columns,
divides the values
in the value column
to produce a table
with one value column.
So how does the join
do that transformation
from two tables to one?
Basically, it's two steps.
The first step, you're
looking at every pair of rows,
one from each of the
two tables, and asking
do they match up in the
time series identifier
fields and the timestamp field?
And when they find two--
a pair that does, we
say we have a match
and we're going to combine
those two input rows
into a row in the output table.
And that's done
basically by taking
the time series
identifier columns
and the timestamp column,
which are the same in both
of those tables, and
those-- that-- those
become the column values
for that row in the output.
And then taking the value column
from one table and value column
from the other, and those become
two value columns in the table.
And this is, basically, your
straightforward, relational
database natural join.
Now, here we just did something
very simple with that table
with two values in it.
We just divided the two
values, but maybe you
want to do something
a little more complex.
Here we're fetching the received
bytes and sent bytes for a pod
and we've joined that,
so now every row in the
has the number of received
bytes and the sent bytes.
And we want the number
of received bytes
as a percent of the
total, so that's
this fairly
straightforward expression.
Val 0 is the first
value in the table,
which is the received bytes.
Val 1 is the second value.
We could have used received byte
count and sent byte count here.
It wouldn't have fit
on this slide as well,
but it would be maybe more
readable in some sense.
We could have done that.
So that's the sum of
bytes sent and received.
Here's the bytes
received times 100
and dividing we get
the percent of those.
So the value table
operation, basically,
allows us to create--
do arbitrary computations
on the input table.
The join can handle
multiple queries in it
and will join them all together.
So you can look at more than
two metrics at the same time,
and you can create more than
one value column on the output.
Unfortunately, at this time,
the metrics explorer will only
display the first
value in the column,
but you might have
additional computations that
could use multiple
values in the row
and the value operation will be
quite happy to do that for you.
All right.
More demoing-- all right.
JD VELASQUEZ: Before
[INAUDIBLE] we actually
had some latency, which is
[INAUDIBLE] we [INAUDIBLE]
see here.
JOHN BANNING: Oh, OK.
Are we going to save the chart?
JD VELASQUEZ: Why not?
JOHN BANNING: Save the
chart, save the world.
JD VELASQUEZ: Yeah,
let's see if it does.
Actually did see a--
it's a latency
[INAUDIBLE] come back--
JOHN BANNING: Let the
latency comes back?
JD VELASQUEZ: Save the chart.
JOHN BANNING: I don't know, JD.
We keep doing this,
they're not going
to believe that we
can actually do it.
All right.
Where are we now?
JD VELASQUEZ: There you go.
JOHN BANNING: We did alerting.
Did we do alerting?
No, we haven't done alerting.
JD VELASQUEZ: Yeah, we
haven't done alerting.
JOHN BANNING: All right.
So one of the things you
might want to do with a query
is to set up an alert with it.
So JD is going to go to the
standard alert creation--
policy creation and we're
going to add the condition.
And here we see an
editing window--
he's going to give the
condition a name-- there he is.
We see an-- our editing
window very similar
to the one we saw before and
with the little editor thing
there and now we're back in
the query notation editor.
JD Is going to add a
query that, basically,
gives the mean utilization
of all of the containers
by location.
And we want to
alert if that gets
too high, so he's going to
put an alert operation there.
The alert operation
has two arguments.
The first is a Boolean
expression, in this case,
just checking a threshold,
but it could be arbitrary
and that when it's true,
says the condition is--
exists.
And the second
argument is a duration
that says how long the
condition has to exist
before we fire an alert.
And having set that up,
we can now save it--
I hope-- there it
goes and so there we
see it in the alert condition.
And the rest of it
is the standard thing
for just setting up alerts,
saying where you want it send,
some documentation.
So we're going to go back
now to the metrics explorer.
We saw a join that joined
two different metrics, now
we're going to
look at a join that
takes one table produced by
the fetch and the filter,
in this example--
that's one table-- and with
the squiggly brackets is going
to apply two continuation
queries to that--
one that's grouping by the kind
of pod, the container it's in,
and the other is grouping
everything together
and giving the total.
We join those two,
and we divide,
and that gives you the
fraction of core usage
time for each kind of pod.
And one nice thing
you can do with that
is to display it with
the stacked area graph
and that shows you a very nice
breakdown of where the CPU
time is going in all of these--
in all of your containers.
Another thing that is something
that you would like to do
is to compare things between
now and sometime in the past.
So here we have a query--
again, we're modifying a table
that was produced by a fetch,
and a filter, and
also a group by--
is all part of
producing a table.
This one gives us,
basically, the sum
of core usage time
for each container
name and we do two things to it.
First, we just add--
on one we just add a
time series identifier
label that says, when is now.
And then the second one
we add a label that says,
when last week.
And then we time shift that--
the table.
And the time shift,
basically, takes one argument
that says how far
are we shifting,
so we're shifting values
in the table from a week
ago to the present.
We're shifting them
forward in time.
So now we have a table for
now and a table for last week
that are both at the same time.
And you can see the tables
here, as JD switches between now
and last week-- you
can see the comparison
between what was going on
last week and next week.
Now, here we used the union
operation rather than the join
to combine the multiple tables
because we wanted to see
both of these independently.
Another way to do this is
we could do a time shift.
Here we are again-- time shift.
One, we're just
changing the name
of the value in the
table and the other
we're shifting by a week
and here we do a join
and then do a division.
And now we see the ratio between
what was going on this week
and what was going on last week.
And some of this
looks highly erratic,
but that's because
this app is driven--
is being driven by robots and
we keep turning them on and off,
so it kind of looks like that.
All right, so time shift.
Another very nice thing
that Stackdriver has
is metadata, which
describes various aspects
of the resources.
And here we have the metadata
node name for a container
and that, basically,
says what node--
what Kubernetes node is
that container running on.
And so here we're
using that as a filter.
We have the name
of a node and we
want to get all of the
containers whose metadata says
I run on that node together.
And that's what this
filter is doing.
And so now we can see,
for a particular node,
what are all the containers
that are running on it.
So metadata is a
very nice thing.
It's useful in
filters now, it'll
be useful before
we get into beta
and a lot of other kinds of
expressions to group by them
or use them in
value expressions.
All right.
And one last thing is--
let's see, oh, no, I've got
a couple of last things.
JD VELASQUEZ: Yeah.
JOHN BANNING: So
the next thing is--
here is a query that, basically,
is got a lot of time series
in it.
And one thing we
might want to do
is to cut that down by
doing a random selection.
And we can do that by
using the top table
operation with the hash time
series identifier operation.
So this is now going
to pick 10 streams
at random by creating a
random hash of the time
series for each--
time series identifier
for each time series
and then just picking the top
10 in that, which will give us
a random selection.
You can see, as JD
moves the cursor
and causes the
thing to recompute,
that the selection changes.
We could put a seed in
here if we wanted to
and then the selection would
be stable and would go on.
Every time we re-evaluate
it, we'd get the same thing.
Depending on what
you want to do,
you want one or
the other of those.
All right.
Another thing we can
do with this or that we
have in the query
notation is macros.
And those can be
used to structure
the way you build a query.
So here we've got a macro called
container metric name, which
takes one param--
data metric, which
contains one parameter,
and fetches a container
and a metric name that's
constructed from the name,
but starts with the Kubernetes
container thing.
Another that just--
another macro that
does a table operation that just
does the filtering that we've
seen before and, a third,
an expression macro that,
basically, does the regular
expression extraction we'd
also seen before.
And now I can express
the that query--
and we've seen this query
before-- but I can express it
in a much more compact way.
And I think at that point,
we're ready to go back
to the presentation.
And all right-- I'd say,
but wait there's more,
the problem is I
think for most--
we've covered most of this
stuff now in the demos--
time shifting,
alerting, metadata,
and filter operations.
One thing we haven't
done is talked
about alignment and time.
You would have
noticed in the group
by example, where I showed
the aggregation computation
marching through
the time series,
that all the time series
timestamps lined up
very nicely.
This typically doesn't
happen automatically.
Or, I mean, it doesn't happen--
isn't naturally the case when
we're collecting metrics.
They tend to be
spread out over time.
And so what has to happen
is a alignment operation
that takes the time series in
a table and lines up the time.
Things that need that
like group by and join--
need that alignment--
will do it automatically,
but you can also do
it explicitly using
an align operation.
Rate allows you to
change from deltas
to streams to rates
from things that
are absolute changes
to changes in time.
And every allows you to control
the period of evaluation
of the queries.
All of the queries we've seen,
up until now, have used about--
a default one minute
evaluation period.
And actually there is
something I want to show you,
if we could go back to
the demo one more time.
Let's go back to that--
sorry JD, I threw a--
JD VELASQUEZ: Where
do you want to show?
JOHN BANNING: Put--
JD VELASQUEZ: The [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN BANNING: Well, that's fine.
Now, you see here that
this shows one minute
interval, which is the interval
of what's showing on the graph.
But if we go to a
week, for example,
we see that the interval--
you have to get--
we see the interval in
the graph is an hour.
So each vertical slice
of the graph is an hour.
Now, we're still executing
the query once every minute
and what you see here,
in fact, if JD would--
if you'll just mouse over the--
something in the-- there we go--
you'll see is that there's
a central line, which
is the average value that
we computed over that hour
and then the range of values--
one minute values that
we saw in the hour.
So you can-- as time gets longer
and the graph less resolute,
we don't lose the spikiness
of the underlying data.
And we could, if we wanted
to go over to the graph
here and add a vertical
bar every one hour.
JD VELASQUEZ: To the--
JOHN BANNING: I'm completely
off the script now.
JD's probably going to kill me.
JD VELASQUEZ: What
you want to do, John?
JOHN BANNING: Align.
There should be align there.
Oh, I'm sorry, every.
I apologize.
There you go and then one h.
Yeah, there you go.
Now, here we're now
calculating the query
at one hour of intervals, which
completely matches the graph
and the shading behind
it showing the spikiness
has gone away.
All right, back to
the presentation.
And we covered everything
else that's on this list.
So I think, JD, it's back
to you to do a recap.
There you go.
JD VELASQUEZ: Thank
you very much, John.
So we showed you
a lot of things.
There's a lot of
information to pack in
and it's a language
that is hard to digest.
Now, the good news is you guys
can access this now and play
with it.
And so if you're a power user,
this is precisely the tool
that you want to use to
get increased observability
of your applications, your
infrastructure, your cloud
services-- whether
it's Google Cloud
or even coming from
other cloud providers--
cloud native infrastructure-- so
every single metric that exists
in Stackdriver and
the time series,
as John mentioned-- if
[? there ?] are in our time
series database, then we
can do all of these things.
And so we introduce the
Stackdriver query notation
as a very flexible language
to, as John showed,
incrementally build and
debug, if you want to,
very powerful metric queries.
Now, you can use
it as we saw partly
with this saving the
dashboards, but to use
it to analyze time
series on demand
and also to save charts--
they are in there--
save charts, and
to create alerts,
and so on-- everything
programmatically,
using this query, saving it--
there's a ton of other
features that the team
is planning to bring about.
So it's, like I said,
if you're a power user
and this is something that
immediately resonates with you,
then you can use it
directly, but we also
have a documentation with--
a cookbook and
examples of things
where you can start
this basic queries
and then extend forward.
Now, Stackdriver is
just available in Alpha
and so you can request access.
We have everything here.
If this works, if not use
the URL that you see there.
It's a closed program
that we're running,
but please do request access.
If you don't get
immediately access to it,
rest assure, as we
expand the program,
we'll grant you access.
We really want to bring
this to all of you and to--
certainly for the team to
get feedback and tell us
how we can make it better and
most useful to your needs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]